so let's talk about what's going on with
Republican senator Mitt Romney
um you know I I think when it comes to
people like Romney we have to be able to
call things what they are and say
compared to this modern trumpian cult
that includes people like Trump Trump's
family Marjorie Taylor green Lauren
bober these types compared to them
Mitt Romney seems and feels so
comparatively benign at the same time
he's still a guy that I disagree with
politically on a number of different
issues Mitt Romney and I have different
economic views views on taxation views
on social welfare programs views on
foreign policy and of course of course
but compared to the completely
delusional weaponized nature of the
modern American trumpian right
he's not nearly as bad and that doesn't
mean we're glorifying Mitt Romney it
just says we're we're talking about
things on a spectrum he has at least
taken like a minor moral stand against
the most insane aspects of the
Republican Party he's anti-trump Etc and
he also mostly voted with the things
that Trump wanted right like roughly 80
percent of the time it's not 95 percent
of the time but it's still 80 percent of
the time and over the weekend Mitt
Romney sort of provided some moral
Clarity on uh CNN about Russia Ukraine
saying it's very clear which side we
should be on here let's take a listen to
Mitt Romney would be done by the U.N or
by us but uh clearly the humanitarian
demand may may be such that that we will
look for a way to allow the mothers and
children that are currently being
huddled in subway stations to be able to
find Refuge right and look at the people
of Poland how heroic they are providing
the clothing and the housing and the
food for these refugees that are that
are pouring into their country and also
in Romania look look this is this is one
of the the greatest demonstrations of
good versus evil that we've seen during
our lifetimes and and the demonstration
of Courage I mean look look at Vladimir
Putin Vladimir Putin here he is in this
this uh behind this huge table in this
big white room I mean it looks like a
mausoleum where where uh honesty and
honor have gone to die and contrast that
was zelenski with his courage with his
passion which with his true leadership
this is remarkable and it's having an
impact and and I hope it makes us a
better people and it makes us more
committed to the principles of Freedom
so this is the perfect example of
differences of opinion with someone who
at least on this issue has his head
modestly on straight versus Insanity
like Biden stole the election Hillary
should be imprisoned the vaccines are
killing people all of that sort of stuff
uh but Romney says Biden has done some
really good things putting pressure on
Russia and he also could have done more
that's a reasonable position I'm going
to go back in time a little bit Senator
do you think it was a mistake for
President Biden to rule out U.S troops
on the ground instead of trying to use
what's known as strategic ambiguity to
deter Vladimir Putin from invading in
the first place
well there really wouldn't have been an
ambiguity we don't have the kind of
troop strength uh and and material of
war in the region to be uh to be a
serious threat at at that point uh look
the the uh the white Administration has
done some things very well and some
things not so well the not so well side
is they continued the policy of Prior
administrations not to provide the
defensive weapons the Ukraine needed
that was the mistake the positive thing
was sharing our intelligence with our
allies and combining our efforts with
our allies look we used to be 40 of the
world economy today we're about half of
that and and so for us to have the kind
of economic clout we used to have back
in the 50s and 60s and 70s we really do
need to combine with our allies and this
is it's it's crazy that like I I don't
love Romney and I disagree with him on
so much stuff but he's at least willing
to say
Biden did some things that were fine and
here's things I would have done
differently whereas you have so many of
these trumpian Republicans now who
anything Biden does anything Biden does
is by definition bad now then he got
into the just absolute Hammer fist drops
on on people like Marjory Taylor green
and gozar he was asked about them and he
just called them morons uh and said that
they're sort of like low IQ people I
mean listen to this this is wild
you talked several times during this
interview about the world seeing the
difference between good and evil I want
to bring that closer to home and talk
about something that congresswoman Liz
Cheney tweeted uh yesterday about
sitting Republican house members
appearing at a white nationalist
Gathering she said quote as
representative Marjorie Taylor green and
Paul gosar speak at this white
supremacist anti-semitic pro-putin event
silenced by Republican Party leaders is
deafening and enabling all Americans
should renounce this garbage and reject
the Putin wing of the GOP now do you
agree
absolutely uh Liz Cheney was right with
that statement and she's been right for
a long time and I also saw uh that uh
that Ronald McDaniel came out with a
statement as well uh talking about how
repugnant these white nationalists are
look there's no place in in either
political party uh for this white
nationalism or racism it's simply wrong
now unfortunately a place has been made
in Romney's party for it like I guess
he's saying there shouldn't be a place
but there's been a place in it for years
now it's it's uh as as you've indicated
speaking of evil it's evil as well and
uh and you know I Marjory Taylor green
and Paul gosar I don't know them but I'm
reminded of that old line from the Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid movie where
where one character says morons I've got
morons on my team and I have to think
anybody that would sit down with white
nationalists and speak at their
conference was certainly missing a few I
keep IQ points
wow wow uh I mean listen he's right he's
right and you can disagree obviously
with someone's politics or beliefs but
appreciate some of the things that they
say or do and it sort of tells you
everything you need to know about the
Republican party that
most of Mitt Romney's utterances today
sound sensible he's still a right winger
in the end but it's such a contrast to
the absurdity I mean remember his gaffe
I've got binders full of women which at
the time was a gaff it's almost quaint
now and I'm not dismissing the fact that
it was sort of inherently kind of you
know the concept of having binders of
women it's all you could argue it sounds
misogynistic and I'm not denying any of
that but compared to what's going on now
even that is a gaff starts to seem
almost quaint so I'm not saying I want
to vote for Romney or anything like that
but the contrast is incredible and he's
right
they have morons in their wings and
unfortunately Romney is the exception at
this point in time unfortunately
Marjorie Taylor green seems to be more
the way that the party is going and
we're going to talk about that next